hi
so today i wanted to talk a little bit
about the five apps that have changed my
life whilst doing my phd and
i've been using different apps for a
while now also during my master's thesis
and during my bachelor's but these five
really stick with me so i think you
could learn a lot if you also start
using them so let's get right into it so
the first app i wanted to talk about is
notion
and i'm always surprised when people say
they don't know notion yet because i'm
such a notion nerd so one thing i do
with notion is i structure my entire
research with it so always when i find a
new paper for example or something that
i discovered there's this really nice
add-on in google chrome and you can just
click on a paper that you really like
and then it automatically syncs to your
notion and then for example i structure
it in to be read read or i already read
it
and then by doing that i kind of create
my own research bank and i also have to
do a lot of programming so when i find
something i want to learn or some skill
i need to do sometimes i also put it in
notion and something else i do a lot
with notion is reviews so this is
something i'm trying to incorporate now
but at the end of the day and at the
beginning of the day i try to do a four
minute review where i kind of go over
the most important tasks i have set that
day or the most important thing i have
to do and by doing this i kind of create
my own diary of my four-year research
and i sometimes go over it so once a
week or once a month i go over all the
little reviews i wrote for the different
days and sometimes something really pops
up so sometimes i see like
i want to do this task and i see that i
have planned it for four days in a row
so then i know like i really need to
start doing this task and stop
procrastinating on it so for me notion
is really an app that every student and
every phd student should be using
because it's just so creative and you
can really make it your own so play
around with it and there are a lot of
dedicated youtubers that make videos
about how to use notion so i'll put them
down below but if you're ever interested
in my workflow i wouldn't mind doing a
video about it so the next app i use a
lot is grammarly and i think every
student should be using gramly if you
haven't heard about gramly it's a really
nice app that just corrects your work
and you have the free version and the
paid version and i personally still use
the free version because i've used the
paid version for a little bit but for me
it didn't upgrade my work that much but
it just corrects your spelling and looks
at all the sentences you make and give
suggestions as to how to change them and
i think if you have to write a lot of
papers or if you have to write a really
big thesis even if you're a brilliant
speller we all make mistakes and
grammarly can really point those out so
that's another recommendation i would
really give the next one may seem really
basic but i'm sometimes really surprised
by how little people use this and that's
google calendar so google calendar i use
as my holy calendar so everything in my
life that i may have to do or i could do
i put in there and for me i don't really
use it as a strict schedule but it's
more a suggestion so a lot of times i
put my time blocks in there so for
example in the morning i put programming
in the afternoon i put research papers
and maybe in the evening i would film a
youtube video or see some friends
something like that and that's more a
suggestion of what i could be doing with
my time so
i think this is really important to do
when you're a phd student otherwise
before you know it you spend the entire
day just doing random little things and
time kind of slips by but doing this you
can really get a nice overview of how
you actually spend your time and also
what you should be spending your time on
and another important benefit is that as
a phd student we have to do a lot of
things we have to give lectures we have
to go to conferences we have meetings
with our professor etc etc and usually
all these things have a dedicated
calendar that you can download and then
just upload to your google calendar such
that you don't have to think about it
anymore it's all set in there so use any
type of calendar but i would recommend
google calendar or i think apple also
has a calendar that's really good and
another app i found lately which has
been amazing is this not really an app
it's a website it's called connected
papers and i'll just show you how it
works real quick so with connected
papers you can just type in any type of
paper you have read recently which you
think is really good and then you want
to find other papers that are related to
it so it gives you this kind of graph
overview of all the papers that have
cited this paper or that have been cited
in the paper and i think this is amazing
when you just start doing research on a
certain topic and you really want to do
a deep dive into that topic because it
gives you a really good overview of what
are the most important papers that you
should be reading but also these more
smaller papers that give some
interesting tiny details that you want
to dive into a little bit more and i'm
now using this as my starting point and
then when i go a bit further i just use
my own research techniques and the last
one i want to talk about is also pretty
basic in a sense but it's to use twitter
and maybe you're thinking like oh i
already use twitter i don't need this
but how i use twitter is actually pretty
different i made a separate account just
for my academic work and the only people
i follow on that twitter account are
academic people or for example writers
or business people that i think i can
use in my work and my twitter because i
do this my twitter has kind of become my
daily news feed of relevant literature
that has come out in the last couple of
weeks because it's so difficult to keep
up with literature by yourself if you're
not following the right people so these
are five apps that i've been using now
and i think there are many more that
could be recommended so if you have any
tips for me i would love to hear them
put them down below in the comments and
see you next time bye